Cuban rhythms are legendary and float
through Havana streets just as they have
for decades the revolution has done
little to dampen Cuban enthusiasm for
their music or the world's desire to
listen people crowd just down the block
to hear accomplished musicians bailed
out salsa merengue and rumba classics
but there's another kind of music
growing in the streets here and despite
the US trade embargo it originated in
New York's South Bronx in the run-down
Havana barrio of Santos Juarez kids play
baseball in the street and a new sound
spills out from hip hop producer Pablo
Herrera's second story apartment it is
because it comes from the voice of those
who are oppressed basically born and
raised in Havana
Pablo became obsessed with American rap
at an early age in 2001 he produced a
Cuban hip hop all-stars album his
apartment is a center for talented
hopefuls to get their message out while
US gangsta rap often rhymes with
violence and drugs
Pablo is promoting artists with a strong
social conscience like the group ZN % o
or 100% borrowing from their African
heritage and traditional Cuban music CN
% o rap about issues that affect
everyday life in the streets like racism
we're a revolution within the revolution
because we're really the next generation
which is coming putting out or opening
up new ideas and we're making our way in
the face of all kinds of hardships
trying to be a part of what makes up the
culture of Cuba itself
in Havana nightclubs it's clear that the
new generation of the revolution is
embracing hip-hop music and fashion and
at Club Las Vegas cn4 Santo aims to
enlighten and entertain the potential to
be the voice within Cuba near Party
Talks
deeply about spiritual